hello everyone
though south korea 2 is still
circulating across the country
cover 19 disease activity indicators
including daily case counts
lab test positivity and wastewater
signals are continuing to decline
currently hospitalizations remain
elevated and variable but there are
signs that severe illness trends are
declining as well
sadly last week
we were reminded of the serious impact
of this pandemic when we surpassed more
than 40 000 deaths
related to covet 19 in canada
to all those in the circle of family and
friends who are grieving at last we
offer condolences
this is a reminder that our efforts are
still needed to prevent every death we
can
one of the things we've learned about
the use of public health measures for
covin 19 in the past two years
is that they were also very effective at
reducing the prevalence of other
infectious diseases
so our reduced contact rates may have
interrupted transmission of other
infectious diseases such as influenza
when most population public health
measures like closures and capacity
limits were removed we saw covert 19
transmission rates rebound and now we're
seeing influenza activity increasing
up to the seasonal threshold despite the
opposite trend being expected at this
time of the year
we remain cautiously optimistic that the
warmer weather months will give us some
reprieve from high transmission rates
nevertheless
personal protective habits help reduce
the spread of covert 19 as well as other
respiratory infections that we haven't
seen for some time while some measures
like masking are in use in high risk
settings the more people who maintain
masking in indoor public spaces or
crowded areas the better they will work
to reduce overall transmission of
respiratory diseases
mass continue to be an important layer
of protection for ourselves while also
helping to protect our loved ones
especially those at high risk of serious
illness
there is still uncertainty with the
covet 19 trajectory and variance
and we still have much to learn about
post covit 19 condition
also known as long covet
maintaining a vaccine plus approach can
keep us better prepared and practice
better protected against serious illness
and other complications of covenant
infection including long covert
this means keeping our covit 19
vaccinations up to date
remaining aware of disease activity in
your local area and continuing to take
personal precautions including staying
home if you are symptomatic or test
positive
improving ventilation and continuing to
wear mass and shared indoor or crowded
spaces when with people you don't live
with
as we go into the long weekend a word of
caution that cover 19 resurgences have
followed social gatherings during past
holidays and long weekends
let's keep doing everything we can to
prevent more illnesses by following the
advice of your local public health
authority
choosing lower risk activities and
settings and keeping up with essential
precautions to help protect the progress
we've made and set us up for a better
summer and a safer for
since we now have two individuals
confirmed to have monkey parks in canada
dr new and i would be happy to answer
questions on monkey parks thank you
merci
merch
bonjour
hello everyone
although
see with signals from wastewater
continue to show a downward trend
currently
the number of hospitalizations remains
high and variable
but there are signs that the
trends are also downward
unfortunately last week
reminded us about the
consequences of this pandemic when we
exceeded 40 000
deaths attributed to
19 in canada
to all those in the circle of family and
friends who are grieving a loss we offer
our condolences this is a reminder that
our efforts are still needed
to prevent every death we can
one of the things we've learned about
the use of public health measures for
covet 19
in the past two years
is that they were also very effective
at reducing the prevalence of other
infectious diseases
so our reduced contact rates
may have interrupted transmission of
other infectious diseases
such as influenza
when most public
health measures for the population like
closures and capacity limits were
removed
we saw
the 19 transmission rates rebound
and now we're seeing
influenza activity increasing up to the
seasonal
threshold despite the opposite trend
being expected at this time of year
we remain
cautiously optimistic
that the warmer weather months
will give us some reprieve from high
transmission rates
nevertheless
personal protective habits help reduce
the spread of covet 19
as well as other respiratory infections
that we haven't seen for some time
while some measures like masking
are in use
in high risk settings
the more people who maintain masking in
indoor public spaces
more crowded areas
the better they will work to reduce
overall transmission of respiratory
diseases
masks continue to be an important layer
of protection for ourselves
and our loved ones
especially those at higher risk of
serious illness
there is still uncertainty with the
covert 19 trajectory at variants
and we still have much to learn
about post coven 19 condition also known
as long coven
maintaining a vaccines plus approach
can keep us better prepared and better
protected against serious illness
and other complications
19 infection
including long coven
this means keeping our covert 19
vaccinations up to date
remaining aware of disease activity in
your local area
and continuing to take personal
precautions
including staying at home if you're
symptomatic or test positive
improving ventilation
and continuing to wear a mask in shared
indoor or crowded spaces
when with people
that you don't live with
as we go into the long weekend
a word of caution
that covert 19 resurgences have followed
social gatherings
during past holidays
and long weekends
let's keep doing everything we can
to prevent more illness
by following the advice of your local
public health authority
choosing lower risk activities and
settings
and keeping up with essential
precautions
to help protect the progress we've made
and set us up for a better summer
and a safer fall
and as dr tam
observed
with the confirmation of our national
laboratory in winnipeg
of the first two cases of monkey pox
from quebec
we are also prepared to answer your
questions
thank you
thank you very much and i would invite
those participants to have a question to
please raise your hand thank you so if
you have a question please raise your
hand
we will start with crystal og from
global crystal i'm going to unmute you
here you go
thanks can you guys hear me
yes great um this is for uh dr tam with
the lab confirmation of the two cases of
monkey pox we now have are there any
indicators at this point in time if it
is a mutation of the virus and what is
the public health agency of canada
looking out for to signal that
yes the um samples from any uh canadian
um cases under investigation are being
sent to the national microbiota the
biology laboratory at this point in time
for diagnosis and for verification
and we hope to be able to expand the
diagnostic capability to other
large provincial laboratories as well
at this point though the national
microbiology lab
is is the focal point for
analyzing any genetic
sequencing
this is
being looked at as we speak
we understand from other countries are
reporting cases
that the current monkey parks strain or
clade if you like is the west african
clade
we have not yet
confirmed that in canada
it would also depend on some of the
quality of the specimens that we get
so
but we will provide that information as
soon as we have it but it would be
through genetic sequencing and
i can't tell you precise time i know
that the diagnosis once the samples got
arrived in winnipeg uh was a very rapid
turnaround for those initial two cases
um but we'll see when the sequencing
can occur and then we will know whether
there's any connections at all
uh with other
identifications
globally
thanks for that um and as a follow-up
according to the who vaccines that were
used to eradicate smallpox are effective
against monkey pox vaccination for
smallpox has dropped off since the
disease was eradicated but the vaccine
is still around how much smallpox
vaccine does canada have stockpiled to
combat the potential monkeypox spread
and what is being done to prepare for
its distribution if it comes to that
yes thank you for that question and
the
vaccines um
currently
being reviewed
are were
essentially developed for the protection
against smallpox
one of the vaccines
has
being
considered for monkey parks as well
using both
immunogenicity
looking at the generation of immune
response and animal studies
so there hasn't essentially been a
clinical trial of the vaccines
against monkey parks itself
but i think uh based on
what we know globally
the
smallpox vaccines can be applied to
monkey parks in particular there is one
that has monkey parks included in its
labeling if you like
so we are having discussions
internationally but also with provincial
counterparts around potential use
um and that we
we have limited supply
but
we can't really disclose the that number
just based on security reasons
yes hello
do you have any reason to believe that
there are other cases
being investigated elsewhere in the
country apart from those in quebec
and
more specifically in montreal and what
is the risk of transmission connected
with monkey parks
thank you for the question
this is doctor
yes
the cases that have been reported in
quebec it's interesting because it
started here in canada with
a case reported in the united states
and when the american authorities
did their follow-up it came out
from the
background of the cases in the united
states that person made a trip to
montreal so it began here in canada
we were in good communication and in
collaboration with our
quebec counterparts to do a follow-up
and investigate that in quebec but of
course it's possible
there are that there are other cases in
canada so
we had a telephone conference with
our counterparts from all the provinces
and territories
and we identified the contact points
for the programs for a possible
investigation in other provinces and
territories
so i think the most important thing now
is really for the entire country
to build the awareness
of health care professionals
to be so to speak
to be properly informed
in case they
see patients that have any signs or
symptoms
that might indicate that it could be a
case of monkey pox but also i think that
we need to
make the entire population aware because
the symptoms and the signs are very
important
it's important to have everyone made
aware
what the symptoms are
it can start with a fever and possibly
headaches and musc muscle pain but after
that is
interesting because
it's a unique
point with this disease which is
skin outbreak there are
bubbles
and it's very important to be aware of
that too
there are
symptoms or signs like that and it's
important to have a
healthcare professional
look at it to go see a healthcare
professional to
have it examined and to take a sample to
have a
diagnosis of a possible case of
monkeypox
as to the mode of transmission based on
our experience so far
normally it requires close contact
with the respiratory droplets
or
body fluids
perhaps from the lesions from the skin
lesions
blisters so
we remain cautious because
based on the experience of the past it's
really connected with travel to africa
but now we have perhaps a bit of
evidence here
even here in in european countries that
there are channels of transmission not
necessarily connected with travel to
africa so i think it's important to
keep in mind
as
required
in order to analyze them
and i'd like to ask the same question as
my colleague from global
it seems that the smallpox vaccine is
quite effective against monkey parked
countries such as spain the united and
the united states have purchased large
quantities in the last few days
has does canada have
smallpox vaccine and if so how much yes
thank you for the question it's
interesting because
smallpox
is a disease that has been eradicated
since 1980
we also know that even though the
disease has been eradicated there may be
still be how should i say this
samples
or perhaps strains in laboratories and
one always has to be ready for
a biological incident
involving smallpox so that's why a
number of countries
including canada
do have a certain quantity
of doses of smallpox vaccine
it's also true that the vaccine is
effective
against monkeypox
vaccine i think it's um
which is now also
authorized and
approved for use against monkey pox
however for the moment
yes we do have
a certain number of doses and we're
always ready we're discussing with the
province of quebec about the possibility
of
perhaps
utilization of it
but this is something where one has to
continue with our efforts and also at
the global scale to
update
the
orientations or directives for the use
because so far
all the indications for smallpox vaccine
are against smallpox but now with
monkeypox of course one has to study
what the indications are and how to go
about using it
to be more effective against that
disease
and with supply this is something which
here in canada we also continue our
efforts
to perhaps
obtain more vaccine
we don't know yet but if it's something
which
for which we have to use it
and the indications
are mainly for smallpox
we will continue with laura osmond from
sippy
can you hear me all right
yes
excuse me i have a sidekick today
um i wanted to ask about monkey pox as
well i was wondering if you can give us
a sense of
how many cases are under investigation
in canada even just an order of
magnitude and if you could just
characterize um what you think the risk
is in canada that this virus sort of
poses
hello psychic
nice to have you around um
we get a lot of those on our virtual
meetings i think um
so
yes um right now i would say
um just under a couple of dozen people
on the
investigation by local authorities
mainly in quebec but a couple of
contacts being followed up in
in british columbia as well but only two
cases confirmed
there are samples on the processing at
the national microbiology lab as we
speak so we might expect to hear more
confirmations in the upcoming hours and
days
we
i think local authorities are still
doing their case contact tracing
um so we don't really know the extent um
to which um the spread has occurred in
canada so that's act on under active
investigation
we do know that as dr new has said in in
in french that the virus is generally
as we know it to this point is generally
spread through close contact and
so that that includes could include
household contacts could it include
other closed contacts and
so far we do know that
not many of these uh individuals are
connected to travel to
africa where the disease is normally
seen
so this is unusual
it's unusual for the world
to see this many cases reported in
different countries
outside of
africa
and so so i think we will let people
know
as soon as we get more information
right now i can't tell you the exact uh
impact
but
i think anyone who um
have
developed some signs and symptoms
including
these
blisters or ulcerative rashes and the
concern should seek
advice from their health care provider i
think at the beginning of any outbreak
we should cast the net why to try and
understand the transmission roots we
don't understand it enough there's
probably been some hidden chains of
transmission that could have occurred
for quite a number of weeks uh given the
sort of global uh situation that we're
seeing right now so we shouldn't rule
out
um you know new things that we might
learn
um as as we go along uh this is an
unusual situation
thank you dr new uh just i'm just gonna
add a couple of other points as dr times
mentioned
i think you know if you're looking at
monkey pox and the fact that it's it
belongs to the same family as smallpox
you know as we uh said earlier you know
you know smallpox was eradicated in 1980
in terms of you know vaccination
campaigns i think in canada that stopped
in the early 70s and so i would say
generally that the entire population is
susceptible to this uh to monkey pox uh
the other part also is that you know
historically our experience with monkey
pox is that it's been travel related you
know it's a someone who's you know maybe
uh been exposed to the virus you know in
africa and then traveled elsewhere and
so the fact that it's now appearing in
uh you know several countries in europe
and and so on and as well as here in
canada uh we we need to to learn more
about it you know has it evolved has it
changed to something different in terms
of
the mode of transmission and so on at
this point it's still uh what we think
uh the the the the motor transition that
we
have seen in the past in terms of close
contact respiratory droplets coming in
contact with you know contaminated body
fluids you know from the pustules uh and
so on and so forth but i think we need
to be uh open that you know that there
may be a something else evolving and
changing i think the overall rest of the
general population is is is is low but i
think the more that people can be i
think uh uh sort of sensitize uh
socialize understand that you know we're
all susceptible and then to be quite
honest it's interesting some of the good
practices that we've all learned with
covert 19 service in good stead you know
against a whole host of other diseases
including this one you know good hand
hygiene you know potentially if you're
if you're feeling sick and have a cough
etc wearing a mask and so on so i think
those are our things that we're looking
at and and we'll continue to examine and
also develop guidance to help healthcare
providers and
and others in terms of how to deal with
this disease as it continues to evolve
thank you
perfect thank you so much i also wanted
to ask you about covid um we've
obviously been detecting cases of ba
0.2.2
um so i'm just wondering if you can sort
of explain how concerned we should be
about this and whether there's potential
for another wave given the new variant
thank you for the question so we're
continuing to monitor the evolution of
the virus
the variants that you were talking about
and i'm not sure which ones but there's
a number of ba2 and related variants
uh we're tracking uh for example ba 2.12
ba 2.12.1 b i think the one that you're
referring to is ba
2.20
um so these are sort of evolution of the
omicron
virus and the ba2 sublineage
so we do know that they're probably
at least related to that lineage um when
we look at
some of the parameters we're learning
about
that some of them might have increased
ability for transmission
uh a bit more increase in transmission
capabilities um that are
um on you know
higher than that of the
ba2 um virus so the ba2 variant so these
we're keeping an eye on it but
so there are always abilities for
um surges to occur particularly in um
under vaccinated populations
and so that that wouldn't be unexpected
what i'm really looking out for of
course are some substantial changes
um where there's an entirely new
variant of concern that are not
omicron variants
but but we will track these i i think
even over the summer months there could
be up and downs
we hope will as i said remain cautiously
optimistic and that will get a little
bit of reprieve um over the next couple
of months and be ready for any
resurgence in the fall but anything can
can happen and we just need to be remain
vigilant all those practices we just all
talked about can help
keep any resurgences
as low as we can
and
keep a more balanced approach to the
ongoing management
yes
hello i'd like to return quickly to
monkey pox
we're talking about an occupation period
that's quite long up to 21 days before
the first symptoms appear
would this lead you believe that there
may be more cases in circulation at the
moment than what has been reported and
does this raise an additional danger
that it could be a long take a long time
before we
are aware that you have monkey pox and
in the meantime it might spread or you
might spread it
yes this is after you thank you for the
question yes we know that
the incubation period
is about
between five and 21 days but
at one point it's one to two weeks
maybe six to 13 or 14 days
so i think it's important to
you know i realized that
the authorities in quebec
with their investigation are doing all
the work
to follow up with the contacts
the contact tracing and there are a
number of suspected cases and we are in
the process of
receiving samples
from the suspected cases in quebec and
apart from that
i cannot really
predict what's going to happen but it is
important to continue the work
in the field
and we'll see what happens
and as i said previously
and we have to build awareness and
discuss it with all the provinces and
territories because as dr tam mentioned
even with the
case from the united states we know now
that there are also perhaps possible
contacting
other provinces such as british columbia
so it's important to continue our
investigation not only in quebec but
perhaps
across the country
okay thank you for that
and i would like to follow up on cover
19
specifically
the b
2.12.1
variant which
now accounts for 43 percent of the
infections in the u.s which
breaks out from the
vaccines and from acquired immunity does
this raise a concern for a more rapid
wave that could occur here in canada as
well an increase in cases such as we see
in the u.s
yes thanks for the question for the
moment we're continuing to monitor that
variant and also all the other variants
that are emerging
and to be a variant of concern well it's
always the three main questions that we
ask
whether it's more transmissible
whether there may be more serious
consequences and as you noted whether
there may be
a breakout from the immunity from
vaccines or even acquired from a
previous infection you know donna
community in the community so
thus far
we're continuing to monitor that we're
not in the same situation as the united
states
and that's why it's very important to
continue
with our efforts
to encourage
and also to increase our vaccine
coverage even though it may
not be as effective against transmission
thus far we see that
vaccines provide good
protection against serious consequences
and that is very important for our
health care system
and it's always important too
to encourage everyone
as always
another increase of
protection from booster shots so we
encourage people to have a third dose
if you're eligible for that
and indeed
advisory committee on vaccines there are
a number of people for example people
age 80 and up
should receive even a fourth dose so i
think this is something to keep track of
and we will see
what is going to happen during the
summer
and we don't know exactly
the situation what the situation is
what's going to happen with the other
variants
it's not only that variant but in
general we do continue to monitor all
variants and we continue to plan
for all
hi doctors i want to thank you for
continuing these briefings and for
following through and having the fourth
dose data posted online i wanted to ask
about ukrainian refugees and vaccination
less than half the population of ukraine
is fully vaccinated you don't need shots
for the emergency travel permit i don't
want to stigmatize asylum seekers but
i'm wondering what role fact has in
helping provinces to make sure that
these shots are available to newcomers
and what you think the provinces should
have in place for these newcomers given
that some canadians are having
difficulty finding covet shots
uh thank you for for that question and i
think uh provinces have been very
collaborative in terms of supporting uh
ukrainian arrive
new arrivals
and including
providing information and in
collaboration with
some ngos that support
newcomers
to give them information
including in appropriate languages
so that they understand
the
need to get the vaccination
and so
there is a
even though there's no requirement to
entry
there is a
federal
requirement to have to get the vaccine
uh within a certain period of time so we
we we wanted to make sure that everybody
uh who arise here understands that and
that the provinces are able to follow up
with them i'm not certain about the
accessibility on the ground but as you
know we have a lot of vaccines and they
they can be accessible in
so many different ways in local areas
but they they are different
distribution points so
i think i would encourage anyone who has
arrived recently from ukraine to make
sure they know how to
connect with the local
public health authorities or even the
local pharmacists
but yes we are trying to work um other
departments not necessarily the agencies
working with arrival
such as
ircc for example um to make sure people
know to get to go and get their shots
and of course they'll all be provided
free of charge
dr knew
an additional point you know if you're
looking at the newcomers uh from ukraine
but just newcomers in general taking a
more holistic
approach to migrant health it's
important to obviously uh welcome them
and have them connected to a healthcare
provider and as a healthcare provider i
wouldn't just be focusing on covet 19
but you know really looking at
all of their their vaccines are they up
to date in terms of you know other
vaccines for the children the childhood
vaccines and for the adults you know do
they need other vaccines to be up to
date so it's not just about covert 19
but i think just sort of a good
vaccination practices and being up to
date with all of your vaccinations thank
you
thank you and on monkey pox uh we've had
other countries note that men who have
sex with men appear to make up a
disproportionate number of cases i'm
wondering if that's happening in the
suspected cases in canada not just the
confirmed ones and if you have any
advice for this group or thoughts about
stigma
uh thank you for the question i think uh
as i said um earlier on we need to look
at all
modes of transmission we do know is
close contact usually uh respiratory
droplets but if you're in close contact
with infected secretions including from
a pasture or an ulcer
if you have a mucous membrane contacts
or a
cut for example that could be different
ways of which
this virus can pass on
and
um and interesting about this
interesting thing about this virus it's
also that we think it can be transmitted
through
contaminated clothing or what we call
foam mites so
um you know i think the the public
should be aware of that
um there may be certain transmission
settings and uh groups of people
currently
experiencing the most cases
but i think i would urge a caution as to
you know essentially focusing on
particular group of individuals
certainly we will provide support and
information
if we are seeing increased cases in
certain populations and make sure they
get information that they need
but i think people should understand
that it's close contact
and that could happen in different ways
households we heard households in the
united kingdom
so uh
so this is why we once must not sing uh
focus on a singular uh group of
individuals and
but we do need to make sure that we have
targeted approaches
that would help individual groups not
everybody gets the information in the
same way so we will be
linking up on on different channels with
non-governmental organizations as well
as the broader messaging to make sure
everyone
gets the same information
autumn
you're looking at the possibility of
increasing the capacity for diagnosis of
monkey box elsewhere in canada
outside of
what's been confirmed by the national
microbiology center
which places are being looked into
to broaden that capacity are there some
priority sites in the scenarios that are
being considered
could you summarize what we know about
those considered scenarios please see
thank you this is dr new perhaps i can
start
yes
that is a
very current issue and we know that
our laboratory in winnipeg
is in close communication and
collaboration with the network of
laboratories of provincial laboratories
across the country
i think we may begin perhaps with
the provinces
that are the largest that have the most
capacity but i cannot give you the
details because i'm not aware of that
it's really a discussion of a technical
nature between our laboratory and the
laboratories of the provinces and
territories
and normally it's also a question of
what is the
state of the technology and the capacity
of those laboratories in the provinces
and territories and of course our
national laboratory is ready to support
all the provinces and territories but
perhaps
it would be feasible if we start with
the
where there's already a certain
technological capacity
to add something
additional to be able to diagnose
the monkey pox
this is
work that is ongoing
for the coming days and weeks
and i could add
that owing to krovet 19
we have more capacity for a diagnosis
from a molecular diagnosis now
thank you very much
and
if i understand
is likely to be the provinces that are
larger or that have a better
technological capacity but do we already
know
which provinces it might be
because we already know that ontario and
quebec are the largest provinces but
will it necessarily be them or is it too
early to say
this is doctor
i can't really say i cannot speak on
behalf of the laboratory
of course our laboratory is in contact
with all the provinces and territories
and this is something which
as things develop
and the discussions continue between our
laboratory and the provinces and
territories
let's move on to
andrew davidson from cbc
andrew are you there
okay we'll move on to hello hello hi
sorry uh
it's actually lauren pelley from cbc
news um
i would hope i would hope you could
explain a bit more about possible
vaccination strategies uh for monkey pox
so we know that uh in other countries
including the uk is now exploring the
notion of a rain strategy where you
vaccinate using the smallpox vaccine
healthcare workers close contacts of
potential cases is that a type of
strategy that you would be interested in
exploring at some point
thank you for the question yes those are
some of the strategy that we're
exploring in connection with the who and
the uk and others
and as dr new had indicated quebec had
some interest in terms of
some of the contacts
so that is under
discussions right now but of course we
need to know some of the epidemiology as
as quickly as possible
um so the vaccinations can be used for
preventive measure
prior to
the exposure or if you oppose exposure
there's also potentially a window of
opportunity to get vaccinated
and so we're looking at all of those
as someone had already mentioned there's
a long incubation period for this virus
and there may be a window of opportunity
to provide a vaccine to certain perhaps
higher risk contacts under those
circumstances so these are under active
discussions as we speak
and one more question on that front as
well uh we've heard from public health
officials in montreal for the general
public to not worry that you can't get
this in a grocery store you can't get
this out and about in public at this
time uh but how how do we know that at
this point because we're also hearing
from virologists that there are major
questions over you know how this virus
may be evolving and are we seeing
changes in it um that could signal uh
you know a shift in in how it transmits
between people and things like that a
lot of unanswered questions at this
point um so what is your take on on sort
of what the real risk is to the public
going forward and what do we still need
to understand about this virus before we
can determine
how much of a risk it poses
so
i think
it's probably
reasonable to
think of this virus as one that is
transmitted through close contact as
we've just described
the respiratory droplets or exchange of
bodily fluids or
from from blisters or
ulcers or others of the skin lesions
but we should of course remain
open-minded as we begin to
investigate this rather unusual event
of spread beyond africa
i think one of the fundamental questions
from my perspective is for example the
role of
asymptomatic
and infected individuals
we haven't got to the bottom of some of
these transmission chains uh
these are just beginning to explode most
people haven't traveled so how has it
been transmitted i think we are basing
the current
information being provided to the public
based on what we know
but we may learn more as we go along uh
so so i think you're right we need to
reserve some
um
you know some of these
risk assessments
um as as as we
go along with the investigation but in
general it's not something that you can
catch
in a casual
contact setting
okay i don't see any more raised hands
uh if the doctor allows we might allow
maybe one more if somebody has an extra
one
i see dylan okay dylan i will let you
ask your question here you go
all right i always have questions um
dr town there's a widespread disparity
in eligibility for fourth shots and
we're seeing that reflected in some of
the provincial uptake so far the age to
qualify is spanning from 18 to 50 to 70.
the nasi uh council is still sticking
with the guidance for 70 and maybe 60.
do you think that needs to be reviewed
or is it true to hold on to these doses
for now if the wastewater is trending
downwards
yes
the national advisory committee on
immunization as you indicated have
provided their recommendation and which
is focused on the highest risks
based on the data that we have in terms
of
the incremental benefits of that fourth
dose
so i think
the committee is
always reviewing evidence on an ongoing
basis
but is not making any changes to his
recommendations at this time i do know
of course provinces are making the
vaccine more accessible
should the public um
want this and they they should know
anyone who's getting that fourth dose
that of course is is off label use
but to the extent that we have the
information at this point it appears um
that
the the the side effect profile isn't
any different uh there is no increase in
side effects compared to the preceding
doses so i think with that in mind uh
anyone who gets the full dose
should make sure that they know all the
information as they they're gonna get it
what you've described i think you're
trying to ask is you know um the timing
of boosters and i think that's a
reasonable point in that
if booster doses they do boost um your
uh the vaccine effectiveness against
infection and transmission but that
wanes over time
so as this current pandemic uh wave may
be coming down
um of course some of the thinking is
that uh maybe that this you know
we will focus our attention um towards
the fall but having said that we can
never guess when that mixed variant
might come up so so these are some of
the difficult decisions as we're going
about a vaccination strategy
um but um
in any case i think provinces
knowing that they have enough vaccines
is making that for those more available
if you don't mind i have one last one in
french
and after that i can assure you that
will be the end overdue sebastian
thank you that's very kind
i wanted to talk to you about
baby formula infant formula there's a
shortage of infant formula that is
hypoallergenic
for
babies with food allergies what is the
current situation and what is the
strategy
in canada to make sure that
those who need it have access to that
product
this is dr new perhaps i could start off
yes we're aware of the situation and we
know that it started in the united
states but
it still has actual impact in canada and
right now we know that our counterparts
in health canada
are in close communication and
collaboration with
the manufacturers and so on and also
with their american
to keep track of the situation here in
canada
and we continue to work to ensure that
we will have
so to speak
infant formula here in canada but of
course we're starting to see
some impacts here and we're continuing
to work
all of our partners on that
so that concludes this
gathering thank you very much dr neo dr
tam for your
time and have a good day everyone